So is there any way to prove
that pidgins never existed,
or can they only not
be proven to exist?
So actually, I
think this question
hinges on the way you def-- on
what you mean by pidgins, what
is meant by pidgins, right?
So at least wanted
define pidgins,
which is to say that there are
these systems of communication
which are created when people
come from different language
background and they
have to communicate,
they have speak to each other.
So like in Africa, in Asia--
in fact, this term pidgin
arose in the coast of China,
and it referred to
this business language
that people used to cross
linguistic barriers.
So from that
perspective, pidgins
do exist, right, if you
take it as that definition.
Pidgins have been documented
over and over again.
They are non-native languages,
and typically, they indeed
reduce in structure.
But as people use
them more and more,
they can develop structure.
So-- go ahead.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I guess my
question be more like, if--
you were saying that there was
no pidgin of Haitian Creole?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: Like, uh-huh, like--
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Right, so this is
where we need to be clear
about how we define pidgins,
because we looked at the
way Bickerton defined it.
So the claim was
a very strong one,
that in the history
of the Creole,
you have this earlier
speech system that's
extremely rich using
structure, and he
was very precise in
terms of what's missing.
And what's missing is affixes--
so no bits of words that can
be used to create larger words.
So we don't have things like
"-er" in English "singer."
So that's a very
extremely precise claims
that, according to
which pidgins are
supposed to be at the bottom
level of language complexity.
They are really simplest
system impossible-- in fact,
even un-language-like.
They might remind us, say, of
the language of homo erectus.
So that claim is a strong
one that we're looking at.
So in the history
of Haitian Creole,
according to the
evidence that we have,
we don't see anything of
that sort that's documented.
So the earliest
archival data source
that we have the
full-fledged language
with all the bells and
whistles, including
affixes, embedding, very complex
language from the very earliest
stages.
You see?
But you seem to have
some doubts about--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because--
I didn't write this question,
but I was still having--
like we can't know if there
was no recording of there
being a pidgin, but maybe
there was no recoding because--
like, if there is a recording,
we're like, OK, oh, then
a pidgin did exist.
But just because
there's no recording,
can we not say that, oh,
maybe there was a spoken one?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Right,
but it was never--
yeah, I can see what
you're trying to drive at.
AUDIENCE: Or if
somebody were to ask--
also, what was in between--
between the current Creole
and the different languages.
If somebody-- how would I--
if somebody were to debate,
it's like, oh, Creole's are--
then how should I respond?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Well,
you could say that--
OK, so actually, Bickerton
has used something
of that kind of argument.
Well, the way he put it,
he put it very succinctly.
He says that "the
absence of evidence
is not evidence of
absence," right,
which is exactly what
you're trying to claim here.
The fellows would not have
that clear kind of data
is that evidence that
this doesn't exists.
It might have existed, but
nobody recorded it, OK?
But in this scenario,
right, the claim
is stronger that--
you see something
like if it could have existed
and nobody could pay attention,
because it could have existed
and be part of a community
to the point, where children
being born in the community
would have used that evidence
to create the creole.
Remember that this
is what you get.
At some point-- let's see.
Let's call it
generation, I don't
know-- let's call it zero.
And for that generation,
all the hearing is--
I think I'm going to have
to use a stronger marker,
so Rachel could you help me?
Maybe this one, it might work.
Let's see.
This is from here.
Oh, yeah. That's better.
OK, so there would
have been enough
of this kind of data for these
children then to use that
and then, from that,
create the creole.
So it's not as if that
this would have been a very
fleeting type of language, so
given that they were observers
of the speech patterns
of that period,
people wrote about the patterns
of the Africans, you see.
It would have been surprising if
it was indeed a communal lingua
franca of sorts, and nobody
noticed that, whoa, there
was a system where all the
French suffixes were gone.
What one could
imagine along the line
was that there might have
been some Africans who
will be producing something
that could be Pidgin-like,
which would be like a second
language version of French--
which is what we expect, right?
Because if you're
learning Italian,
you might go to a stage where
you produce Italian verbs
without affixes, right?
And from that perspective, yes,
one could imagine that there
would be some speakers
producing Pidgin-like data,
but could there be a whole
community that would be using
that Pidgin--
including, say, people in
their own homes to the point
where the children
would be only getting--
because remember
that for Bickerton,
the crucial fifth piece is
that you have children here,
and the children are
transforming this Pidgin
into a Creole.
And then you get, at
a later generation,
it's called this, I
don't know, plus one.
Then you get the Creole
becoming a stable language
from the Pidgin.
AUDIENCE: And too, like,
[INAUDIBLE] like tunneling
the people [INAUDIBLE]?
Would it be done,
like, that people
were keeping their languages
while this was being developed
at the same time?
Or that how it would be-- is
that how it happened with like,
were people keeping
their African languages--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah, in
fact, there is reports.
So someone like
Toussaint L'Ouverture,
for example, the
well-known Haitian leader,
was claimed to also speak
African languages from, say,
the Bay family, so this is
likely that one could imagine
at some point there would be
many speakers in the community
who would be bilingual
or trilingual,
even speaking four
or five languages.
But the question
here is whether there
was anything like
what Bickerton posits,
that was spoken
across the community
to the point where the children
had no choice but to use
only the speech and data to
create the native creole,
and the evidence is not there.
And also, structurally--
and this is what we see.
So maybe we should come
back to that question
when we look at the
data, because we're
going to come back to
the data that we have
and try to make
sense of this claim.
AUDIENCE: If you think about
the situation with Spanish--
or with Spanglish in
the US, it's very--
I mean, I would say that
there's several generations that
speak it.
I also would say that it's
relatively unstable in the way
that a Pidgin might
be, but I also
wouldn't know what
the difference would
be between an unstable Pidgin
and code switching in the sense
that, like, if you think about
more of a modern day example,
I would say that Spanglish
is the best candidate,
but that also is my concern.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: But again--
so that's a good point
that you're bringing up here.
So the idea is that
would Spanglish be
anything like a Pidgin, right?
And first of all, I would
say that the conditions that
surrounds Spanglish are very
different from those that
surrounded, say, the
creation of Haitian creole,
so in terms of just a mix, you
see-- so in Haitian creole,
where we have lots of African
languages being spoken
and plus many
varieties of French.
There wasn't just one French.
There were many languages
that were now called French,
but in fact they were
quite different in terms
of the structures-- what
the French themselves
called the Patois, right.
AUDIENCE: I thought when
we talked about Pidgins,
we talked about Pidgins
as non-genetic languages,
so then, if we're looking
at that definition,
then technically the only
Pidgins would be the very, very
first languages.
So then you can't
have creole of Pidgin,
because it is influenced
or derived from something?
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Well, that's what
we're going to see exactly--
that in a way, there's a
sense in which by using that--
[INAUDIBLE] creoles
derive from Pidgin,
you're already creating a
bias against the area that--
the Africans, actually
they were learning
French in the same way,
say, that the French people
themselves in Europe, back
when France was being created,
were learning Latin.
And in fact, we're going to
look at some data like that.
OK, so this is all
good, so you guys
have been have been asking
all the right questions.